a show of forced by the Philippines and
the United States the annual joint
drills are known as palikatan which
means shoulder to shoulder they opened
on Tuesday with more than 12 000
American and 5 400 Filipino military
personnel taking part this year's
balakratan will be the biggest ever
indication of growth of
how it continues to evolve to meet our
shared goals
in the first for the annual drills a
mock enemy ship will be sunk in the
south of China Sea the war games
followed three weeks of drills on land
involving the Philippine Army and U.S
forces
they begin only a day after China ended
exercises practicing Precision targets
and blockades around Taiwan a
self-governed island which China views
as its own
all of which these protesters say could
be seen as provocative and pose a danger
to Filipinos this is not about
Philippine sovereignty this is not about
helping us in the west Philippines Sea
against China this is about asserting
and projecting U.S power and the U.S
preparing for war
and such concern extends Beyond
balikatan
protesters here
in a larger presence of American
soldiers after the government last week
said they'll have access to four other
Philippine military sites bringing the
total to nine
president Ferdinand Marcos Jr has
downplayed fears the Philippines could
be used as a launching pad by the U.S
as three of the four new locations are
near Taiwan reaction in China
China's reaction is expected because
they have their own concerns but the
Philippines will not allow our own bases
to be used for any offensive action
says the Philippines is attacked and
that scenario is to be rehearsed in the
coming days as tensions rise further
across the region
below Al Jazeera Manila